it's a girl congratulations
during their cbs primetime special with
oprah prince harry and meghan markle
revealed the gender of their second
child let's
god go gonna have a daughter
the duke and duchess of sussex are
expecting their first daughter
this summer nearly two years after they
welcomed their son archie
we've got our family we've got you know
the four of us and our two dogs and
done it's great the couple also
confirmed that their plan is to stop
after two children done two is it
done two is it two is it in the first
portion of the interview
megan opened up to oprah one-on-one
about her pregnancy with archie
megan shared what it was like learning
that their child would not be receiving
a title or
security he wasn't going to receive
security
this went on for the last few months of
our pregnancy
where i'm going hold on a second i'm
like no no no
because if he's not going to be a prince
he's like okay well he needs to be safe
so we're not saying don't make him a
prince she also revealed details about a
shocking conversation that took place
about her firstborn
we have in tandem the conversation of he
won't be
given security he's not going to be
given a title
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
there's a conversation with you
with harry about
how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like
the duchess said she would not disclose
who had the conversation with harry
and that it would be quote damaging to
the person who brought it up
they were concerned that if he were to
brown that that would be a problem are
you saying that
i wasn't able to follow up with why but
that if that's the assumption you're
making i think that feels like a pretty
safe one
et spoke to royal expert katie nicholl
before the specials
the subject of race is is definitely
going to be something that is going to
be raised clearly it's something megan
wants to talk about she hasn't had the
chance to talk about it
my understanding is that she is going to
discuss
racism in britain but also within the
royal family
absolutely no suggestion that she's
going to accuse the queen
of racism but i'm told that there are
some members of the royal family
who she who she may be pinpointing
despite the heavy subject matter
discussed in the two-hour interview
harry and megan insist they live a happy
life now
and even gave a glimpse into life with
archie with this home video of him on
the beach
so your story with the prince does have
a happy ending
it does a greater than any fairy tale
you've ever read
greater than anything